was rauskommt präsidentschaft hat ja
gesagt ja ich weiß nicht ob ich das so
anerkennen werde ich gehe wahrscheinlich
vor gericht wie stehst du dazu
also wir haben schon ein paar
spielereien gesehen in pennsylvania
also wenn man es muss zu gericht gehen
das muss so sein es war im jahr 2000
zwischen büschen sorry nicolas ich muss
man ganz kurz in meinem redakteure regie
reden
gregor du bist die ganze zeit draußen
auf den lautsprecher zu hören
also sorry wenn ihr meinen redakteur
gehört habe er hat sich in der tasse
vertan so er ist glaube ich haben wir
alle technik fehler die man machen kann
ausgeglichen
die leitung zu dir nicolas steht
wundervoll für alle die sich nicht
kennen haben aber ganz kurzen film
gemacht wo würdig vorgestellt haben
bitte a
er ist ein glühender trump fällen
nicolas smith aus kalifornien er hat
sechs jahre in deutschland gelebt und
hatte einen burger laden in essen schon
2016 hat er trump gewählt und lautstark
für ihn getrommelt war mehrfach zu gast
bei maybrit illner
der steht eigentlich für hoffnung
mittlerweile lebt nicola smith wieder in
den usa arbeitet dort als lehrer und er
will dass trump an der macht bleibt
dann spreche ich weiter mit nikolaus
hoffentlich jetzt ohne technische
schwierigkeiten
nicolas die große frage die sich
wahrscheinlich viele in deutschland
stellen die ja eher skeptisch gegenüber
donald trump sind ist warum möchtest du
diesen präsidenten wieder noch mal vier
jahre an der macht sehen wir haben so
viel wachstum gesehen
jetzt schafft er hat alle seine ich
glaube alle die hier die menschen die
hatten angst
vor donald trump sind jetzt nach nach
sillian falsch bewiesen
also ich denke seine unterstützung es
ist größer als vor vier jahren und ich
denke er war nenner als als im 2006
sehen
aber warte mal wenn du sagst alle seine
versprechen hat er gehalten
bauer nach mexiko ist nicht
fertiggestellt wurde nicht von mexiko
bezahlt so erstes versprechen nicht
gehalten er hat gesagt der wirtschaft
geht es besser wir werden unser
handelsdefizit runterschrauben fakt ist
das handelsdefizit ist hoch geschraubt
wurden wegen der handelskriege mit in
diversen handelspartnern das alleine
sind zwei versprechen die sehr wichtig
waren die gebrochen wurden störte ich
das überhaupt nicht also wir haben mehr
mehr arbeitsplätze in 2009/10 gehabt als
als nie vor
also arbeitslosigkeit hier alle gruppen
bunny so guten 2009 10
und wenn denn wir haben wachs wachstum
hier
das ist eigentlich egal ob das bedeutet
mehr oder weniger handels unterschieden
mit china also ich denke der hat
eigentlich nicht sein versprechen halten
und der mauer ist das kommt noch das ist
halb fertig und ich denke die nächsten
vier jahren wird das fertig sein und
mexiko wird bezahlen oder glaubst du da
nicht mehr dran
das ist komplexer die bezahlen
mit steuern also die wenn die einträge
in den usa sie müssen die steuer
bezahlen wenn die produkte von mexiko
exportieren müssen die steuer bezahlen
also die die db bezahlen wie die mauer
also ok du meinst die bezahlen klassen
in german in germany sa über bande so
indirekt quasi das ist was ist mit
anderen skandalen diester gab ich nenne
mal ja der versuch immigranten illegale
immigranten aufzuhalten eltern von den
kindern zu trennen wir haben vor kurzem
erfahren über 500 eltern sind immer noch
nicht also sind verschwunden man weiß
nicht wo die sind die kinder sitzen in
in der obhut des amerikanischen staates
ist das nichts was du sagst das ist
jetzt keine unbedingt gute politik die
du nochmal sehen möchtest also die die
politik über über illegale immigranten
hat schon angefangen vor trump also das
ist nicht schuld dass das was passiert
ist und viele kinder sind ohne die
eltern von mexiko mit mit kriminellen
akt nach amerika geschickt also dass das
passiert das ist traurig wenn das
passiert aber trump hat keine schuld ich
habe meine frage fand ich von burhan
medica auf facebook kemmer jeder andere
republikaner für dich in frage also
wählst du quasi donald trump weil der
republikaner ist und du einfach aus
überzeugung republikanische ist und
niemals demokratisch oder ist er für
dich eine art idol niqab obama zweimal
gewählt
ich hab' ich war schon in die
vergangenheit demokrat eigentlich also
ich finde seine seine ideen sind einfach
besser
wir haben obama aktie gegeben er hat
viel gesagt aber nicht viel getan und
und trump ist ein
er ist dem bug was er sagt jetzt ist
eine andere frage noch vor auf youtube
von blablabla was denkst du warum die
mainstream medien so negativ über trump
berichten
ich denke dass sie sind aktivisten
geworden
so wie die die die menschen die arbeiten
mit die umfragen also wir haben gesehen
der letzte mal wie falsch die die
umfragen vor der wahl war und ich glaube
wenn die sind nur in die großen städte
die haben keine ahnung was passiert in
denen den ganzen land und wie du schon
gesagt hast wir haben ein ganz großes
land und wenn die bleiben einfach in new
york oder los angeles
die haben einen falsche einblick was was
die normale amerikanischen wähler denken
und münchen
aber es gibt ja noch viele sachen also
die kann man durchaus kritisieren
findest du gar nichts kritikwürdig an
donald trump und seiner politik sei es
seine äußerung über über frauen griffen
beide pussys sachen dass er sich nicht
wirklich von von weißen rassistischen
organisationen distanziert sind das
keine sachen gibt es gar nichts
kritikwürdiges für an ihn für dich also
den kritik dass er das ist ist ist total
falsch dass überhaupt kein rassist und
die andere sagen das ist einfach das ist
nicht wichtig das portal sagen gesagt
hatten die vergangenheit was wichtig ist
ist dass der der gewinnt 44 america und
die amerikaner und also die andere erste
test an nicolas dass ich so viele
schwarzafrikaner also afroamerikaner von
donald trump nicht vertreten fühlen und
ihm wirklich rassismus vorwerfen das ist
eine große bewegung gibt wie blackwater
die sagt die tante police wir haben eine
rassistische struktur hier ist es über
und er das einfach komplett negiert und
auch diese leute auch nicht zugeht
das ist total falsch wir haben kein
rassistischer system hier und wir werden
sehen dass er mehr unterstützung von
americana und history of america dieses
mal hat ich denke sie werden überrascht
sein aber er hatte doch vier jahre zeit
sie zu überzeugen und das resultat war
dass im gesamten jahr 2020 sehr viele
von ihnen auf der straße war
und gesagt haben das geht so nicht und
wir haben ein rassistisches system
wir haben leider ein problem mit mit mit
ein paar polizisten die die haben gewalt
in den falsches situation genutzt und
das hat nix mit präsident trump sie tun
und die denke heute abend oder morgen
oder übermorgen wir werden sehen dass
viele amerikaner finden dass das dort
ist der wichtige mensch wird den den
platz als präsident und dass er kein
rassist ist
glaubst du auch dass der umgang mit dem
corona virus für ihn wirklich positiv
war also er hat sehr lange negiert ich
glaube über 30 mal
da hat er gesagt es wird magisch auf
magische weise verschwinden es gibt so
viele tote in den usa an oder mit dem
corona virus wie weltweit nirgendwo
da hat er doch zumindest nach der
bewertung von vielen beobachtern kein
besonders gutes bild abgegeben
die krone
dies ist eine neue seite für jeder und
der hat das gemacht so gut wie wie
möglich und hat die ausgangssperre oder
die einreisesperre meine ich viel china
und europa ganze markt also ich denke
der hat eigentlich tausende von menschen
[Musik]
gerettet eigentlich wenn mit seiner
seine politik aber wie erklärst du dann
dass es über 230.000 tote in den usa
gibt also so viel wie nirgendwo anders
auf der welt als wir haben ein großes
land also wenn man guckt auch auf europa
die haben vielleicht mehr
ausgangssperren gehabt es gibt einen
unterschied also das ist relativ hoch in
den usa also höher als in anderen
ländern
wir sind ein großer
350 millionen menschen hier also dass es
gibt mehr tote dass die signifikant
höher ist die usa als in anderen ländern
ich denke das ist falsch weil jedes
bundesstadt zählt die menschen die die
tod von krones unterschiedlich und viel
schutt geht auch auf die demokratische
gouverneur in new york zum beispiel der
hat kranke menschen kommt mit gronemeyer
sorgt in altes heimat geschickt und auch
in kalifornien und ich denke die ja mehr
schutz als aus schrank das hat
eigentlich wenig mit dem zu tun sondern
mit unserer gouverneur wir haben einen
der bundes system wie in deutschland und
die staaten die bundesstaaten haben viel
macht in einer gesundheits sagen
trägst du privat eine maske oder bist du
auch jemand der das nicht tut weil er
glaubte es wirkt nicht also dass man
muss das tragen ihren kalifornien
aber ich bin der meinung dass man soll
frei sein um das zu sagen wenn er wenn
ihr möchtet oder nicht wenn er keine
lust hat und die menschen die ihr müsst
die misch sind total sicher sein so
einfach zu hause bleiben
selber und wir wollen ein freies land
und ich denke dass es gegen die freiheit
dass menschen sollen masken oder müssen
masken tragen oder muss zu hause bleiben
oder oder die geschäfte zu machen aber
sie gefährden damit doch über die
sexuelle gefährdet damit doch andere
menschen wenn sie das virus in sich
tragen und das vielleicht gar nicht
wissen
das ist ja nicht nur eine persönliche
entscheidung für sich selber sondern
auch für andere
ja aber die menschen die haben angst vor
dem virus so einfach zu hause bleiben
das ist eine sehr einfache antwort
findest du nicht das ist die das ist der
antwort dass sie
ist das ist eine einfache lösung es ist
keine lösung das wir müssen die ganze
gesellschaft schließt sind wenn mehr als
99 prozent von den menschen die sind
erkältet mit krone was überlegen was
also das mag keinen sinn mehr
am anfang wir wir haben nicht so viel
über den videos gewusst aber jetzt wir
wissen dass einfach nur die menschen
über 75 das ist gefährlich für die aber
für jüngere menschen für den meisten das
ist nicht so gefährlich
ich habe hier noch fragen für dich aus
der zuschauerschaft vom feuerwehrauto
auf youtube ihn würde interessieren was
du vom wahlsystem in den usa heißt was
ja dazu geführt hat beim letzten mal das
eigentlich hillary clinton mehr stimmen
bekam und trotzdem nicht präsidentin
wurde das ist für uns deutsche sehr
schwer nachzuvollziehen wo wir ja
mehrheitswahlrecht haben ist es für dich
ein faireres wahlsystem
auf jeden fall also wir haben wie ich
gesagt habe
350 millionen menschen und 50
bundesstaaten
und wenn das würde eine einfache
mehrheit
wenn eine einfache mehrheit wird könnte
den präsident das würde bedeuten dass
new york und los angeles und san
francisco und einfach die große ganz
große
städten des landes könnte jedes mal alle
macht nützen und wir haben dieses system
entwickelt so dass die menschen die
wollen auf dem land und und die mitte
des landes zum beispiel in wyoming und
lasko und arizona und alle die die
kleine bundesstaaten würden auch einen
einfluss auf die politik haben aber das
heißt ja dass du deine stimme in groß
wie kalifornien das heißt aber dass
deine stimme in kalifornien de facto
weniger wert ist als die stimme von
jemandem in wyoming
das ist doch egal nein das ist nicht so
weil es gibt mehr wahl also es gibt die
die wahlmänner sind ja nicht wirklich
proportional anhand der bevölkerung
sondern das ist ja teilweise etwas
unausgewogen so dass eben dann diese
stimmen mehr gewicht haben in der
wahlmänner auszählung als tatsächlich
wahlstimmen gibt man könnte das so sehen
aber das ist wichtig dass jeder soll die
menschen die wollen die städten und auf
dem land haben eins ist auch auf was
passiert in washington und ich denke wir
würden ganz viele probleme haben wenn
der in new york und noch seinen du es
könnte könnte den ganzen land übernehmen
also dass das ist intelligent ausgedacht
unser system so mehr wird jetzt hier
vorgeworfen ich würde parteiische frage
stellen nein ich führe ein sogenanntes
kritisches interview mit nicolas die
stelle in kritische fragen er antwortet
darauf das war so abgesprochen ich glaub
nikolaus ist okay damit darauf hat er
sich eingerichtet von daher alles gut
ich habe hier noch eine frage einmal die
frage warum bekommst du redezeit ich
finde oder wir finden das ist wichtig
mit allen seiten zu reden das ist
tatsächlich sehr schwierig mit trump
unterstützern zu reden weil es nicht
wenige also es gibt wenige in
deutschland und es gibt noch weniger die
deutsch sprechen in den usa von daher
sind wenn nicolas sehr dankbar dass er
uns mal einen blick in seiner
argumentation gibt
eine frage noch von vinzenz pongratz auf
youtube was hältst du von der klimakrise
donald trump ist da jemand der aus dem
pariser klimaabkommen ausgetreten ist er
immer wieder angezweifelt hat dass die
klimakrise menschen gemacht ist obwohl
sein land also euer land sehr viel co2
in die luft stößt bist du da auf seiner
linie auch politisch also deutschland
hat unser co2 reduziert in die letzten
vier jahren mehr als in deutschland also
ich denke das ist ganz wichtig dass wir
unterstützen die natur und und keine
keine klimakrise machen aber ich denke
dass es gibt verschiedene wege um um die
richtige die richtige ergebnis zu haben
also mit mit technologie und und alles
wir werden eine lösung finden
ob donald trump tatsächlich mehr co2
also weniger zäh und mehr co2
eingespannt ist deutschland kann ich es
gerade nicht so richtig überprüfen
auf jeden fall weiß ich dass er immer
wieder geleugnet hat dass es eine
klimakrise gibt die vom menschen gemacht
ist bist du da bitter chor
ich denke das ist ein bisschen ein
bisschen übertrieben
wir müssen wir müssen beachten dass wir
die rede die die kläger nicht verstehen
aber das ist wichtig 1 1 krise im moment
gibt glaube ich eigentlich nicht obwohl
die gletscher so stark schmerzen wie
noch nie zuvor alle arktis forscher
waren uns schmilzt grabe der ganze pohl
weg findest du wir haben kann der
klimakrise also ich bin kein klima
wissenschaftler und ich behaupte sie
auch nicht also was die den daten
was das bedeutet müssen wir waren ein
bisschen naja ich rede mit
klimaforschern ich lebe mit rede wird
klimawissenschaftlern und die sagen mir
dass alles und von daher bin ich
geneigt den zu glauben ok nikolaus ich
habe jetzt noch jede menge fragen für
dich aber wir haben jetzt schon selber
eingeredet deswegen möchte ich mich bei
dir bedanken für deiner zeit und dass du
dich diesem gespräch gestellt hast eine
letzte frage vielleicht noch was machst
du denn morgen früh werden rauskommen
joe biden wird präsident ich muss das
akzeptieren dass amerikaner also wenn er
gewinnt ich hoffe dass er viel erfolg
hat aber ich denke wir werden sehen dass
donald trump gewinnt und die
republikaner beharrten den senat eine
große mehrheit und werden den der hosted
service centers wieder übernehmen mit
mit einer eine mehrheit
aber du bist wie ich sagte du bist sehr
optimistisch wir sind gespannt was die
nächsten stunden ergeben werden vielen
dank nikolaus nach fresno kalifornien
für diese einschätzungen und deine
ansichten ich schaue jetzt nochmal ob
die leitungen zu meiner kollegin alicia
nach washington
noch steht die ja und vielleicht mit
besserem ton diesmal nein höre ich nicht
aber die fixkosten
morgen früh noch mal reden alex du hast
gerade bis hin zu gehört was nikolaus
gesorgt hat sind das ansichten die wir
sind das ansichten die der vertraut
vorkommen du bist ja sehr viel
rumgereist jetzt in den letzten wochen
durch 13 bundesstaaten hast du voices of
america quasi gemacht hast die menschen
gefragt wie sie denken ist auf seine
eine typische haltung von trump
sympathisanten
ich denke auf jeden fall da sind jetzt
einige sachen gefallen die kommen hier
sehr vertraut und sehr bekannt vor denn
was ganz klar stimmt was nicolas ja auch
gesagt hat ist in der mitte des landes
sieht es ganz anders aus als an den
küsten und in den großen städten
denn in der mitte des landes gibt es
sehr sehr viele unterstützerinnen und
das ist sehr sehr republikanisch geprägt
es sind auch andere sorgen und
bedürfnisse auf dem land und da ist auch
tatsächlich die die im versprechungen
von törns sind sehr gut angekommen dass
er eben etwas für die arbeiter tun
möchte für die fahrradtour möchte aber
auch ganz wichtig viele sind auf
ernüchtert und viele ich habe den
fahrern gesprochen beispielsweise die
sich auch nicht nur positiv geäußert
haben also haben im prinzip dortmund ii
profitiert die einen größeren betrieb
hatten und die mit dem kleineren betrieb
denen ging es nicht so gut und da habe
ich einige stimmen gehört die eben
gesagt haben wird meine stimmung wohl
diesmal nicht mehr anschauen gehen aber
was eben stimmt ist dass tatsächlich die
mitte des landes hier andere bedürfnisse
hat als menschen in den großen städten
also damit hat er recht und von denen
von den themen her
es ist tatsächlich auch so dass da also
sehr sehr unterschiedliche dinge einfach
noch alle spielen für republikaner oder
für demokraten eine sache die ich jetzt
immer wieder gehört oder gelesen habe in
interviews oder oder porträts über trump
wähler die sagten ja er ist mir ein
bisschen unangenehm ja ich finde nicht
alles gut was er macht ja sogar
teilweise ich finde ihn täglich ich
wähle ihn aber trotzdem kannst du uns
erklären was dahinter steckt dass man
einen präsidenten unterstützt den man
eigentlich persönlich ablehnt
auch das stimmt und auch das habe ich
öfter jetzt in den letzten wochen und
monaten gehört ich glaube was ganz stark
im moment
dazu beiträgt ist das vielen menschen
ist in diesem land wirklich nicht gut
geht es wirtschaftlich nicht gut geht
wie so vielen menschen auf dieser welt
aber wie wir alle wissen in den usa ist
auch tatsächlich also die
wirtschaftliche situation massiv hat
sich verschlechtert für viele menschen
es sind sehr viele menschen arbeitslos
und wissen einfach nicht wie es
weitergeht und da habe ich einige
stimmen gehört von von menschen die eben
gesagt haben ja ich mag ihnen vielleicht
als mensch nicht ich traue ihm aber zu
dass er mir wirtschaftlich mich hier das
land wieder auf die füße und somit auch
natürlich dann eigene persönliche
situation verbessern kann
also hier ist dann auch ganz stark geht
das jetzt hier hand in hand mit corona
also wir stimmen hier ab während einer
corona pandemie und natürlich ist auch
corona hier 1 1 das entscheidende oder
eines der entscheidenden themen im
wahlkampf gewesen
nochmal abschätzen oder abschließend
eine abschätzung es gab in den letzten
tagen auch wirklich auseinandersetzungen
handgreifliche auseinandersetzungen
zwischen den verschiedenen lagern beide
lager sind teilweise bewaffnet sowohl
black lace meter aktivisten sind mit
gewehren und schwer bewaffnet
aufgetreten
republikanische milizen sowieso für wie
wahrscheinlich heißt das dass es
eventuell hierzu wirklich schweren
auseinandersetzungen kommen kann
das ist schwierig zu beantworten
tatsächlich ich glaube und hoffe das ist
jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz so
dramatisch wird nichtsdestotrotz ich
kann sicher gerne trage ich hier unten
drunter trage ich unten drunter eine
weste die zumindest gummigeschosse
aufhalten könnte und hier steht german
tv um mich eben als presse ausweisen zu
können
also es ist nicht so als wären wir nicht
vorbereitet darauf denn auch tatsächlich
die ganze stadt in washington downtown
alle geschäfte sind vernagelt mit
brettern
also man hat sich jetzt auch sag ich
jetzt mal das schlimmste vorbereitet
aber es sind eben auch ganz viele
friedliche proteste mit musik und tanz
angekündigt also natürlich ist die
hoffnung dass jetzt nicht hier zum
äußersten kommen aber
viele menschen sind auch darauf
vorbereitet das ist auch einfach
natürlich bei diesem bei diesen
erhitzten gemütern im moment bei diesem
grund verschiedene meinungen auch zu
auseinandersetzungen kommen kann ja gut
wir hoffen wirklich das allerbeste du
bist die nächsten stunden weiterhin
unterwegs für uns vor allem auf unserem
instagram kanal zdf reutte da gibt es
dann stories von dir also da wird nur
einmal folgen vielleicht einmal die zdf
heute herunter lagen da gibt es die
runterladen da gibt es die ganze zeit
updates von uns in der wahl nach gleich
folgt im linearen fernsehen was sich
etwas unterscheidet von dem was wir hier
machen
ein zdf spezial ab 0.10 gibt es die
wahlnacht im zdf wir senden die ganze
nacht durch bis morgen früh und wir sind
an dieser stelle mit alisa dietz schon
wieder verschwunden ist wieder hier für
euch um 730 gibt es hier unser zdf heute
live spezial zur wahlnacht und den
ergebnissen alister wird uns dann sagen
die letzten stunden verlaufen sind für
alle die quasi als lieber was anderes
gucken möchten im stream auch fein wir
sind morgen früh wir das für euch da und
ich sage jetzt erst mal macht's gut bis
dahin
vielen dank fürs zu sehen und tschüss